حرب الاتهامات المتبادله تشتعل من جديد
بين الرئيس الاوكراني بلودوميرزنسكي
وطهران اتهامات لطالما تمحورت حول دعم
ايران لروسيا بالمسيرات التي يتم
استخدامها ضد اوكرانيا موقف جديد من
الجانب الايراني جاءك رد على تحرك زينسكي
الاخير الذي دعا فيه الشعب الايراني الى
ممارسه ضغوط على حكومته للتوقف عن امداد
موسكو بالطائرات المسيره حيث انتقدت من
خلاله طهران الرئيس الاوكراني ووصف
التحركاته بالاستعراض السياسي المصحوب
بالدعاءات لا اساس لها وهنا اكدت ايران ان
زليسكي ومع اقتراب موعد الهجوم المضاد
الذي يمكن ان تنفذه كييف على مراحل يسعى
الى تحصيل اكبر قدر ممكن من الاسلحه
والمساعدات الماليه من الدول الغربيه
بتكثيفه الاتهامات لايران
وكانت واشنطن ودول غربيه فرضت عقوبات على
ايران لدعمها الجانب الروسي بمسيارات
استخدمت لضرب اهداف في كييف قالت ايران
حينها انها ارسلتها لروسيا قبل الحرب فيما
لم تؤكد موسكو ذلك
الموقف الايراني يتزامن مع استمرار
انتقادات الرئيس الاوكراني لدعم طهران
المتواصل لروسيا بمسيارات انتحاريه تستهدف
مناطق سكنيه في بلاده
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات